[Musik]
auf jeden fall ich glaube dass wir
comedians eine große aufgabe jetzt vor
uns haben die leute zu unterhalten
wir haben natürlich auch diskutiert die
leute feiern ihre geburtstage moment
nicht dürfen wir unser jubiläum feiern
40 jahre verstehen sie spaß und wir sind
ja mal ein jahr
wir versuchen heute abend die leute zu
unterhalten
versuchen sie zum lachen zu bringen es
gibt viele menschen in deutschland die
existenzsorgen habe gesundheitlich
angeschlagen sind und für die sind wir
heute abend da um gute laune zu
verbreiten wie daraufhin eine live-show
in zeiten von krone ab das team ist sehr
klein alle müssen abstand halten alle
haben masken ich habe auch eine bei der
probe normalerweise immer an und wir
müssen uns die hände desinfizieren
es ist ganz anders als sonst aber darin
liegt wahrscheinlich auch die große
herausforderung
sie wollen hier auch die ehemalige
moderatorin frank elstner und paola
felix dazu schalten sind sie gespannt
wie es bei denen zu hause aussieht also
bei paola weiß ist wenn die nicht groß
um geräumt hat da war ich vor zehn
jahren zu gast und dann auch noch mal
vor acht jahren zu gast da kenne ich
mich ein bisschen aus bei frank elstner
war ich noch nicht das wird spannend
sein so ein bisschen zu sehen wie ihre
frank eingerichtet ist kurt felix hat
die steuer vor über 40 jahren erfunden
sie haben damals kennengelernt was wenn
man haben sie da kennen gelernt also ich
war sehr nervös als ich vor zehn jahren
zum 30-jährigen jubiläum nach st gallen
geflogen bin und hab bei den beiden
geklingelt ich wurde per handschlag
begrüßt persie und nach dreieinhalb
stunden haben wir uns umarmt und waren
alle per du
kurt felix habe ich kennengelernt als
ein ganz ganz tollen mann tollen ehemann
einen sehr sehr akribischen arbeiter und
der auch mir viel glück gewünscht habe
mir einige tipps gegeben hat und er ist
für mich ein typischer schweizer der
dazu auch noch sehr viel humor hat was
glauben sie schaut er heute abend von
oben aus zu 100 prozent da bin ich mehr
so sicher kurt felix wird heute abend
von oben von seinem plätzchen dem himmel
zu schauen
seine frau die daumen drücke mir die
daumen drücken und er wird irgendwo
einen softeis automaten hingestellt
haben der natürlich ein bisschen
manipuliert ist damit an
spaß haben dann wünschen wir ihnen eine
schöne sendung und viel spaß heute abend
dankeschön dankeschön dankeschön